we are stretching dollars on this
memorial day mini kickoff of course that
barbecue season today so i stopped by
seoul valley barbecue in the arts
district to chat with celebrity chef
bruce calman on friday he showed us how
to make the best pork shoulder one of
the more affordable cuts of meat out
there today the sides are still in the
show
dishes that we we serve
most economical i would say you know
potato salad
potatoes aren't that expensive
this is literally five ingredients
potatoes parsley
um well four ingredients
mustard mustard and mayonnaise and then
our texas ranch beans this is a more
complex recipe okay but we we do
soak dried beans we do it all fresh we
cure our own bacon for it and then it
has a lot of like the meat scraps from
when we're cutting
in there as well if you want to do that
home super cheap you could do what
canned beans and throw in some yes
you know what bushes and heinz beans i
grew up eating all that they're great
they're actually great
and you could add add your own touch to
it okay uh and then our coleslaw again
simple coleslaw cabbage
um carrots and then our simple croissant
dressing we we do a sort of a sweet and
tart creamy dressing
which people aren't are it's a jersey
thing i grew up i grew up in jersey so
you got a little chat for all you texans
out there that love our barbecue i grew
up in jersey
you know what you're doing okay so
that's kind of
i mean that's the basis of it you can
buy anything you want here but
ultimately yeah if you want to stretch
your dollar and then you can just pork
shoulder yeah and then you can do this
you get a little some cheap white bread
which cheap white bread is essential for
great barbecue
you know some pulled pork
a little bit of
coleslaw on there
a little bit of carolina sauce
you got that
epic memorial day ready
you have to lean in i do have to lean in
should i you can do this
you got it
[Laughter]
you won't regret it
two thumbs up chef awesome thank you as
always appreciate you
here you go memorial day barbecue
kickoff
and i did not bite his fingers i'll have
you all know
you wanted to
i was pretty close though if you
missed a chev's pork shoulder ideas it's
on our website 8newsnow.com